next position opening titles is a new
one
oh wait no it's not that's been a thing
since the beginning of time you might as
well have just sung the series of
unfortunate events to the tune of
gilligan's island
it does robot voice laser sound and fart
noise
also known as the tv since trifecta my
crotch is itchy
come on let me see crotch gazing gene
you're outside nicely offering people a
free sample all right but why are your
samples full burger sliders
i've been to enough malls in sam's clubs
in my day to know that samples are when
you cut up a regular product into
bite-sized pieces
and stick a toothpick into it so that
when i walk by i can accidentally grab
three toothpicks instead of one
i can't keep track of who's in mourning
and who isn't just
anyone with an urn that seems like a
limited view what about the people who
chose to have their loved ones buried
instead of cremated
i know you think it's the gene show out
there but there's a line between
entertaining and annoying paul stanley's
comments to gene simmons before kiss's
first concert somehow make their way
into this episode
cash only listen you're my children and
i love you
but you're all terrible at what you do
so why are they the ones doing it again
i know you said something about you and
linda having to grind the meat but
unless that actually is a euphemism does
that really need to be a two-person job
and couldn't it have been done a bit
more ahead of time what was the date the
date
yes the date of our wedding oh crap
is it today husband forgets his
anniversary cliche
how do you think it good it went very
well that's
good boy or girl h john benjamin is one
of the best voice actors working today
however even though the professions
couldn't be any more different bob's
inability to be even one percent of a
decent human being is so archer i just
keep hearing
lana every time he opens his mouth
health inspector
the burger joints natural enemy pretty
sure that's chick-fil-a but
semantics also when we saw linda less
than a minute ago she was storming off
saying they were done
so what brought her back to the meat
table so fast did someone actually order
this
yeah who him he looks like a child
molester judging a book by its comb over
cover
this poor excuse for a teacher almost
connected her w drew a horrible excuse
for an ampersand and only filled in the
top of the exclamation point on show
until day it's called the pursuit of
excellence susan
look it up human flesh roll burger
marshalls
this is one of our biggest weekends you
can't put that up nobody will eat here
my guess is even if the hda has a sign
that states a restaurant's food may
contain human flesh once in the window
customers don't really have much of a
choice on whether or not they will eat
it said establishment
it would be closed until the
investigation is completed sorry
the lab's closed till monday considering
it's labor day weekend i believe you
meant the labs closed till tuesday
why is green shirt sweatpants guy still
here just hanging out reading this
poster when 30 seconds ago he screamed
in sheer terror what does he expect to
find on this sign that he hasn't already
absorbed he saw people in
food he freaked the [ __ ] out and what
now examining the print quality
now why would you do something like that
honey why
better question why hasn't the sign for
today's burger special been changed from
the controversial child molester back to
new baconings it's almost like the show
wants this restaurant to fail and i
don't know what i'm rooting for
i mean if you're gonna do clever pun
shop names like this one we're not
not going to remove a sin right toilet
with stalls
also answering your cell phone in a
public restroom or
any restroom who's that for mort he
called in his order
why in the name of arcasia are you
delivering a burger to the crematorium
during a controversy about you using
their bodies for meat
gee i wonder if that will result in
another big misunderstanding that can
further the hilarity of the plot
hilarious right can you imagine someone
being so obsessed with hand sanitizer
what is that stuff even good for
these signs are hilarious but there
should be a question mark after the word
beef and i'm an epic [ __ ] so
we write hurtful things on poster board
considering this don't taste me bro
picket sign made me laugh for five
minutes straight i'm pretty sure you
mispronounced hilarious
people who keep snow globes readily
available in their bag what is he saying
out there what you can't hear him that's
strange because in a minute you'll have
an entire conversation through that
window without even raising your voice
you can't have it both ways glassholes
apparently when they broke this glass
they broke its ability to reflect as
well since bob's
eyes close and open after they do in
real life and so help me if one of you
comment hound says something about the
speed of light meaning the reflection
should happen after
i will remind you he's standing a foot
away and the difference should be
imperceptible to the human eye
also his eyes here are open for a full
second while they stay closed in the
reflection
so show clearly doesn't know how to
reflection properly and i'm adding
another four sins for the hand cramps
from pausing and rewinding
well we might have some more human meat
but it's uh
fifty dollars a burger soylent gouging
this turned into a great weekend
bob wearing his apron on the ferris
wheel during family time is horrible
have you ever worked in a kitchen you
take the smell home with you
it lives inside of you and even one of
those natural loofahs that removes sick
skin layers can't help the stench why
would you wear your meaty greasy apron
outside of the restaurant
i'm getting scarred for life up here
well that's the end of the show and
while we all laugh at their misfortunes
i'm left wondering
why the hell tina's crotch itched until
the bacon grease somehow helped get that
kid to a
doctor
silent green is people
for some reason you all want to wear the
cinemasins pitchfork m on your body
so we slapped that [ __ ] on some new
merch and threw it in the store posters
hoodies
tanks socks click on the merch below the
youtube player or click the store link
at cinemasins.com
welcome to gitburger home of the good
burger can i take your order
you're smiling with your eyes guys keep
the eyes smizing
lips are no mccain how many toothpicks
on the ground
hey two eight two eight two i'd hate to
get any saliva on you
and mr perfect moisture mouth yes all of
it
you fox-eared [ __ ] good luck with the
angry mob bob
the only significant difference between
those other guys and me bob
is that i'm gonna kill you we know you
people and you know
us you're thinking of this place all
wrong as if i had the money back in a
safe
the money's not here well your money's
in joe's house that's right next to
yours
and in the kennedy house and mrs
maklin's house